the mean emission of all engines of a
new design needs to be below 20 parts
per million if the design is to meet new
emission requirements 10 engines are
manufactured for testing purposes and
the emission level of each is determined
the emission data is and they give us 10
data points for the 10 test engines and
I went ahead and calculated the mean of
these data points the sample mean is 17
point one seven and the standard
deviation of these 10 data points right
here is two point nine eight the sample
standard deviation does the data supply
sufficient evidence to conclude that
this type of engine meets the new
standard assume we are willing to take a
type or we are willing to risk a type 1
error with a probability of 0.01 and
we'll touch on this in a second before
we do that let's just define what our
null hypothesis and our alternative
hypothesis are willing to be our null
hypothesis our null hypothesis can be
that we don't meet the standards that we
just barely don't meet the standards
that the mean of our new engines is
exactly 20 parts 20 parts per million
and you essentially want the best
possible value where we still don't meet
or the lowest possible value where we
still don't meet the standard and then
our alternative hypothesis our
alternative hypothesis no we do meet the
standard that then the true mean for our
new engines is below 20 parts per
million and to see if the data that we
have is sufficient what we're going to
do is assume we're going to assume that
this is true
we are going to assume we are going to
assume that is true and given that this
is true if we assume this is true and
the probability of this occurring and
the probability of getting a sample mean
of that is less than 1% then we will
reject the null hypothesis so we are
going to reject we are going to reject
our null hypothesis if if the
probability of getting a sample mean of
17 point 1 7 given the null hypothesis
is true is less than 1 percent and
notice if we do it this way there will
be less than a 1% chance that we are
making a type 1 error a type 1 errors
that were
ejecting it even though it's true here
there's only a 1% chance that or less
than a 1% chance that we will reject it
if it is true now the next thing we have
to think about is what type of
distribution we should think about and
the I guess the first thing that rings
in my brain is we only have 10 samples
here we only have 10 samples we have a
small sample size right over here so
we're going to be dealing with a
t-distribution and a t-statistic so with
that said so let's think of it this way
there's going to have some we can come
up with a t statistic that is based on
these statistics right over here so the
T statistic is going to be 17 point one
seven our sample mean minus the assumed
population mean minus 20 parts per
million minus 20 parts per million over
our sample standard deviation over our
sample standard deviation two point nine
eight two point nine eight this is
really the definition of the T statistic
and hopefully we see now that this
really comes from a z-score and we the T
distribution is kind of an engineered
version of the normal distribution using
T statistics two point nine eight
divided by the square root of our sample
size we have ten samples so it's divided
by the square root of ten and so this
value right here let me get the
calculator out just to get a value in
place there just get a value in place so
this is going to be 17 point one seven
minus twenty close parenthesis divided
by divided by two point nine eight
divided by the square root the square
root that's not what I wanted let me
complete that let me go back divided by
the square root of ten and then close
parenthesis and then close parenthesis
it is almost exactly negative three our
teeth that statistic is almost exactly
negative three negative three point zero
zero and what we need to figure out
because T statistics have a T
distribution so what we need to figure
out is the probability of getting this T
statistic
or a value of t equal to this or less
than this is that less than 1% so the
way we can think about it is we have a T
distribution we have a T distribution
let's say we have a normalized
t-distribution right the distribution of
all the T statistics would be a
normalized t-distribution this is the
mean of the T distribution there's going
to be some threshold there's going to be
some threshold t-value some threat
threshold T value right here so this is
our threshold t-value Thresh threshold
threshold and my writing isn't that easy
to view well let's just take it this is
some threshold T value right over here
and we want a threshold T value such
that any p value less than that or the
probability of getting a t-value less
than that is 1% the probability of
getting a t-value less than that is 1%
so that entire area in yellow is 1% we
need to figure out a threshold T value
there and this is for a T distribution
this is for a T distribution that has
that has n equal to 10 or 10 minus 1
equals 9 degrees of freedom degrees of
freedom so what is that threshold value
over there and notice that this is a
one-sided distribution we care about
this is 1% and then all of this stuff
over here
all of this stuff over here is going to
be 99% and just the way most tea tables
are set up they don't set up a negative
T value that is oriented like this
they'll just give you a positive T value
that's oriented the other way so the way
tea tables and I have one that we're
going to use in a second right over here
the way tea tables are set up is you
have your distribution like this and
they will just give a positive T value
they will give a positive T value over
here some threshold value where the
probability of getting a t-value above
that is going to be 1% and the
probability of getting a t-value below
that below that is going to be is going
to be 99% and you can see that well we
know T distributions are
ar-ar-ar symmetric around there mean so
whatever value this is if this number is
2 then this value is just going to be
negative 2 so we just have to keep that
in mind but the T tables actually help
us figure out this value so let's figure
out a T value where the probability of
getting a t-value below that is 99% once
again this is a one-sided this is going
to be a one-sided district or one-sided
the one-sided situation so let's look at
that over here so with one-sided
this is just straight from Wikipedia one
side we want the cumulative distribution
below that T value to be 99% we have it
right over here 99% we have 9 degrees of
freedom we have 10 data points 10 minus
1 is 9 9 degrees of freedom so a team
our threshold t-value here is 2.8 to 1
so our threshold t-value in the case
that we care about is just the flip this
over it's completely symmetric is
negative two point eight to one so what
this tells us is the probability of
getting a t-value less than negative two
point eight to one is going to be one
percent now we got a value that's a good
bit less than that we got a T value we
got of T value of negative three we got
a T value right here our T statistic of
negative three right over here so that
definitely goes into our our I guess you
could call it our area of of rejection
that the problem this this is even less
probable than the 1% we can even figure
it out that the the area the area over
here the the probability of getting a t
statistic less than negative three is
even less than it's a subset of this
yellow area right over here so so
because the probability of getting the T
statistic that we actually got is let is
less than one percent we can safely
reject the null hypothesis we can safely
reject the null hypothesis and feel and
feel pretty good about our alternate
hypothesis right over here
that we do meet the emission standards
and we know that we are we have a lower
than 1% chance of actually making a type
1 error in this circumstance